Samuel lives here and the big problem
with most property investors is they
don't know how to work out the return on
investment when buying properties if you
want to be able to do that stay tuned
I'm about to explain how when most
people buy properties they buy with
their feelings and not with their
formulas and that always ends in a
disaster so you want to be buying with
formulas and what I mean by that is
working out what the return on
investment is how do you work out the
return on investment it's really really
simple when you buy the property there's
only two figures that you need to look
at and then those two figures you divide
together and that gives you the return
and what are those Digitas number one is
how much money are you putting into the
deal in total so that would be the
deposit any refurb on the property any
legal fees set up stamp duty how much
money are you putting down in total in
the property that's the first figure so
when you're back to buy property right
that figure down second figure is how
much annual income or annual cash flow
profit whatever are you going to be
making from that property now I'm not
talking about how much you're gonna have
to rent the property out for I'm talking
about what's the profit so how you gonna
work that out is you're going to take
the annual profit which is the rent and
then you're going to knock off the
expenses and mortgage payments voids
management maintenance all the figures
that are going to happen or I usually
say 10% for management and 10% for
maintenance so how much are you actually
going to be left with in profit cash
flow then you divide the annual profit
by the total investment times that
figure by 100 and that will give you
boom the ROI return on investment and
that is the only thing that you should
be thinking about when buying properties
what's the return on investment now in
my opinion if the return is less than 20
percent I'm not interested it's got to
be higher than 20 percent and on top of
that of course you're going to benefit
from capital appreciation now on my two
day program the property investors crash
course we actually give out
a sheet which will calculate return on
investment so a monkey can do it it's
just a case of like take the forms fill
out the boxes and then you'll be able to
see how much your property will give you
as a return on investment and you should
be able to do that in five minutes flat
every time you look at a property and
those of you that have been on the crash
course will know that by the end of the
crash course you'll be able to find
properties that give you twenty percent
and above return on investment it's
incredible so hope that's been helpful
if you haven't books on the crash course
yet then you are an idiot
so get yourself booked on and I really
afford to seeing you guys next time
thank you so much for watching
[Music]